this may be the biggest story of our
lives and there's questions about
historic moments in our lifetime that uh
may be bigger you know 911 being one of
those moments we were just talking about
this before the show and uh FairPoint
FairPoint I understand but this this
could be
I don't know maybe it's a little bit
hyperbolic but this is this is a
dramatic Revolution this is a dramatic
change Donald Trump is facing
136 years in prison let me say that one
more time Donald Trump is facing after
his arrest his his arraignment
136 years in prison
now I can't imagine this going anywhere
Beyond where it's already gone because
this is a ridiculous charge what's
happening even CNN has come out and said
this is underwhelming there's nothing
new in these charges it's exactly what
everyone said it was going to be it is
Donald Trump paid hush money to Stormy
Daniels the statue of limitations is two
years it's been seven there's nothing to
escalate these these these charges to
felonies except Bragg says this was done
to conceal a different crime
which is going unnamed
so I consider this to be unprecedented I
think everyone does we've never seen an
arrest like this but
it's it's it's not just the arrest of a
former president it is the use of
trumped up false charges in plain view
of even CNN
they have become so extreme
so it has become so egregious that they
are outright taking action that even CNN
is like what is this
so Donald Trump is going to be giving
remarks in about 15 minutes and we will
pull up those comments listen to what he
has to say and provide commentary as
well but we'll cover the the breaking
news first however before we do today's
episode is sponsored by cast brew coffee
it's actually us it's our own coffee
brand you can see of course there is a
rooster as the mascot because we love
Roberto Jr he's the greatest and you can
pick up our signature Blends rise with
Roberto Jr a light roast breakfast Blend
or Appalachian nights a dark roast for
those that like light or dark roast and
of course we do have a uh we have a
medium roast option with our Colombian
and French roast which is a little on
the medium to dark side you know French
roast French roast is pretty dark but uh
we decided to sponsor ourselves and make
our own company so if you want to
support our work you can go to
castbrew.com pre-order because we've
just started production and they will
ship by May 5th also don't forget to go
to timcast.com click join us become a
member and you'll get access to our
Discord server where you can actually
surely call into this job you've been a
member for at least six months at ten
dollars per month you will get access to
the VIP chat Channel where you can
submit questions and call into our
uncensored after show or you can sign up
at 25 a month to jump the line these
gates are here to keep out extremists
and and activists and people who want to
spy or cause problems it's not perfect
but
it's the best we could do and uh
at about 10 10 pm we'll have an after
show tonight where we'll take calls from
you guys who are members so don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this historical moment is Lisa Reynolds
hey thanks for having me happy to be
back I wish it was better circumstances
but here we go here you are uh who are
you what do you do oh um I guess I'm a
political jack of all trades I'm a
former Hill staff or political
consultant sometimes commentator you
know I used to write for lives of tick
tock I think all right right on well
thanks for for joining to talk about
this thanks for having me we also got
Phil abanti hanging out how you doing
Phil Labonte uh lead singer of All That
Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary my buddy Ian
Crossland what's happening I'm Gonna
Roll the D100 on the off chance I get
100 things are going to work themselves
up peacefully
it's rolling it's rolling right now it's
going to be a one
oh no it's going towards one got a one
percent chance of this working out it's
a 70. okay it almost went to the one
though that was scary yep yep well I
guess we're gonna have to do something
about it then 70's pretty good yeah yeah
so uh put some effort in that's Ian for
everybody introduction yeah I'm a crazy
man welcome to my world hi Serge hello
hey what's up Ian I like being your
world it's pretty chill man yeah anyways
let's get rolling let's jump into this
first story we've got this from Vanity
Fair Donald Trump is now facing wait for
it
136 years in prison now for those that
are tuning to the live show and about 10
minutes Trump will be delivering remarks
we have that stream ready to go I'm
gonna move it out of the way so we can
monitor that and get ready for Donald
Trump's statement in the meantime here's
the story from Vanity Fair oh and you
know they're loving this they write as
you've no doubt heard by now Donald
Trump was charged on Tuesday with an
astonishing 34 felony counts of
falsifying business records in the first
degree now here's the thing it's the
same thing they charge them 34 times for
the same thing
as Maggie Haberman reported not only did
the ex-president look very unhappy as he
walked into the courtroom but he
appeared as angry as he did after the
axis Hollywood tape went public in
October 2016. why might Trump not have
cartwheeled into the courtroom with a
huge grin in his face snapping his
fingers and blowing aircons into the
cameras for one thing Tuesday marked
what was effectively the first time he'd
ever been truly held accountable for
anything in his life for another he's
facing more than 100 years in prison 34
Class E felonies 136 years in prison
which is an incredibly huge number now
my question for this ridiculous article
and for these people is
are they happy that a misdemeanor
booking bookkeeping error is going to
result in two life terms
they don't care CNN ran a poll
and they asked do you believe this was
politically motivated almost everyone
said he has like 80 percent said yes
they said do you think it's a good thing
and they said yes they don't care
Democrats mostly Democrats said it was
good that for political reasons
two-thirds two-thirds two-thirds of
America of respondents because you don't
know I don't know the details of the
poll but two-thirds of the respondents
to that poll are
are believe something that is
antithetical to all liberal principles
it is wrong to use the government to go
after your political opponents because
they are the your political opponents
right that is that is straight up stuff
that happens in banana republics and the
reason that these countries are banana
republics is because of the organization
of their government they are illiberal
they try to do things like give
everything to everybody like trying well
hold on but they believe I got to
interrupt you okay Banana Republic you
know where it comes from right go ahead
it comes from when uh what was it
Nicaragua I think it was or which
country the United States because oh
because of the Dual yeah right right
right it's the US's corporate
intervention yeah but but I'm being a
bit pedantic yeah we understand usually
Honduras in Costa Rica there you go
Honduras usually they they are because
they have illiberal policies and even
even the the type of of corporate and
and government collusion that is also
illiberal but point taken yes to call
them banana republics but when they
think he's literally Hitler they've been
told over and over again you would do
asteroid literally Hitler Hitler and
that's what they think he is so they're
fine with it it doesn't matter what our
constitution says it doesn't matter what
our our justice system looks like it
doesn't matter if it has negative
consequences for even people on their
side going forward it doesn't do you
guys think we talked about this a moment
ago before the show started but I want
to ask now for everybody listening do
you think this is the biggest story in a
uh of Our Generation
I 911 I don't we might be the general I
think I'm in a generation different
slight from you like I was the end of X
you're the beginning of the next one so
for me it was 9 11. 911 because it was
sending we still didn't know it was like
three years that we didn't understand
911 which was made it much worse this at
least we have light on it right now 911
was catastrophic but it brought the
country more together this is for Our
Generation something that is the most
divisive in our country there's an
argument to be made that 911 is what set
all of this in motion so 911 the United
States the response the United States
has to 911 where the U.S really really
clamps down on on data data and
information and stuff like that and
spying and really violates the
Constitution I think that there's an
argument to be made that 911 changed
America so much that made this moment
possible but at the same time uh it is
reasonable to say that the the clear
political uh you know attack on the
president by putting your political
opponent in jail that is a watershed
moment that is without question if it's
if it's not the most uh impactful
um and I think it remains to be seen
whether or not it will be if it's not
it's definitely among the top two or
three would you say oh sorry would you
say that it's coordinated like Bragg is
like coordinating with the we were
talking about this earlier in like a
Twitter space or whatever but do you
think it's coordinated like Bragg is
working with the Democrat Party or he's
just like a road a rogue actor doing it
just for himself because you know he
that's what he ran on and he wants to
make a name for himself but the vibe I
get is that it's that it's coordinated
or at least planned or that it's because
I was re-watching the debates between
Hillary and Donald again like I watched
a little before and you know there's a
whole thing of she's talking glad you're
not in charge of the law and he's like
because you'd be in jail then another
segment they're debating and Donald's
like you know I didn't want to say this
but I'm gonna say it when I get into
Power I'm going to have a special
prosecutor look into your emails like he
was totally telling her on stage I'm
gonna charge I'm gonna go after you and
investigate you when I become president
so like he opened the gates to this well
he didn't do it though he did he didn't
do it and we should now I mean there
should be he should have done it he
should have he should have 100 I don't
know I think the president's bad whoever
does it because he should have done it
as an attack on the bureaucracy it it is
not because because the secretary of
state is a bureaucratic position right
so Hillary Clinton was the Secretary of
State that's when she that's when she
imagined that's the or The Story Goes
that he doesn't he chickened out yeah he
did he got it and then he's like no no
we're not going to do that we're not
going to do that and then behind closed
doors they were sitting there saying
themselves we have to crush him in any
way possible
they tweeted that what was it the day he
got inaugurated they were going to
impeach him 100 the lawyer who was
involved in the first impeachment
tweeted at him we will impeach you yep
they had been working non-stop to make
up a reason to go after him and now that
he's running again and they know he's
doing well in the polls this is what
they do 136 years in prison I don't I
think they would have done this
regardless of how he was doing in the
polls to be honest absolutely because
they I think that this is punishment I
think that this is punishment from The
Establishment to you know punishing
Donald Trump and you know the January
6th there's the same thing the reason
that they you know sat in jail for
trespassing charges you know
unprecedented treatment uh for for
trespassing and the like is is because
of it is you it is the government
punishing people that would challenge
their Authority even if you would
ostensibly use your own you know use
things that are you know actions that
are protected by the Constitution to get
people used to that type of behavior and
persecution and to scare them like so
you know everybody was saying don't go
out and protest it's a trap Feds all
that kind of thing well that's exactly
what they wanted to do they wanted to
scare you and think that it was feds and
that you needed to stay home and that if
you did go out it was going to go crazy
and you were going to be arrested and so
effectively they got what they wanted
either way either you stay home and you
don't do anything and you're safe or you
go out and you know that you're the
government's going to be weaponized
against you and everybody especially on
the left is okay with that yeah it these
are all political litmus tests or or
um you know population lit necesses see
how much the people will put up well so
I asked the Charlie crickets the other
day I'll ask you Lisa do you think Trump
gets convicted yes I'll tell you why I
mean absolutely we have we have this
first of all the judge needs to recuse
himself because of his daughter but even
if he doesn't right why because of his
daughter his daughter is
um working for Kamala Harris the judge's
daughter is working with Kamal Harris so
she needs to he needs to recuse himself
clearly I don't think that's going to
happen but that's what needs to be done
but I've been in I've actually been on
trial and my judge like I was in for a
trade secrets case and my judge
specifically said because you
hyperlinked the where the information
was publicly available you're not
allowed instead of like showing them
screenshots of the actual websites
you're not allowed to tell the jury that
at all I'm like well it's a trade
secrets case and if it's public and I
can show that it's public on the
internet then how can I not present that
to the jury he didn't like my attorney
but I mean we still won but like I was
not allowed to tell the jury that all
this information was publicly available
on websites these for motions and
lemonade which is what the jury is
allowed to say the judge can rule on
almost anything not being presented to
the jury as like bias or whatever they
want yes but let me add
you could literally show the jury a
video recording of Michael Cohen smoking
a cigar being like you know the nice
thing I'm gonna do is yeah I'm gonna
falsely accuse Trump get him locked up
that's not a jury and the jury is going
to be like yeah I don't care Trump goes
to prison agreed agreed so that was the
second part so a even if you have one
like you know righty on the jury pool
you have a judge that's already likely
going to bias the information that he
gives the jury and then look where
you're pulling from so I know that
they're trying to get it um the case
transferred to Staten Island or
something like that they're going to put
a motion in for that emotion to dismiss
but we both know that this judge isn't
going to approve any of that I have a
desperate plea to the Deep State and the
shadow government listening you guys
this is too much like Nazi Germany the
the people no screaming out about the
Communist liberal Democrats just like
the Nazis were screaming about the
Communist liberal Democrats people
screaming out about the fake news nope
like the like Gobles were screaming
about the fake news and then they put
when they put Hitler in jail is when he
became very radicalized and you do not
want to do that to someone that 40
million people are following right now
right now there's like three deep State
guys and one guy sitting there and a
single tier goes on his cheek and he's
like he's right you guys we gotta call
this off no it's not gonna happen no way
I mean it it it's it's a noble noble uh
statement to make but this is this is
exactly what they want and there are
people that given the opportunity would
put Donald we'll put Donald Trump away
for the rest of his life but I do got to
say part of me is imagining this future
where like it's 300 years and there's
like a space station and this teacher
has got a bunch of little future kids
and she's walking up to a giant statue
of Ian in the space Colony orbital ship
and she's like before the start of the
second Civil War one person fought to
keep this country United and it was only
after years of fighting did he finally
reunite the country and save Earth I
think it's like a big Ian wearing a
purple Blazer look at his face he's like
oh God I'm having visions put me in
touch with the shadow government there's
a deep state that is like the
administrator to state but then there's
a this according to Alex Jones I asked
them the difference between the Deep
State and Shadow government he said the
shadow government's like a government
that has its own military its own up
everything existing beyond all countries
that is there just in case there's a
nuclear war they'll keep continuity of
government yeah I'm talking to yeah The
Enclave I want to get in touch with you
guys help you build space force defend
against drone swarms make the world
peace for real
we believe you you look you look very
sincere so there's repurpose the
military industrial complex to start
building drone what we need to focus on
drones and not blown up humans sorry Tim
what are you saying Jose is a president
National Security Presidential Directive
51 I believe it was
the division games are based on this
that in the event of catastrophic loss
of human life or economic damage the
president can create a new government
replacing the U.S government
that's that's something that George W
bush created and it's never been tested
but
it it can never be tested in the event
that some catastrophic moment happens
maybe the dollar collapses or something
economy we're a Great Depression they'll
just do it and no one will be able to
challenge them it's just it's just that
I imagine they're underground because
it's for nuclear well Alex said it was
for nuclear war like the surface gets
totaled it's supposed to keep Humanity
going well not Humanity the government
yep yes government yeah and henceforth
Humanity
utilitarian view yeah I mean it is it is
humanity is second order I will continue
I should say the the humanity is the
fact that Humanity gets you know
continues is a byproduct of the
government continuing they want the
government to continue they need people
so that if they could have ai do it and
like only a couple people they would be
fine with that I don't know if I brought
this up on the show I think we truly
could repurpose our military-industrial
complex Boeing who's we uh the United
whoever the people that run Lockheed we
could be like okay instead of building
they don't want to missiles lives are
better the way their lives are better
building but think about the Drone
storms that are coming because
drones and then take them out into space
arm them with like laser sensors so they
don't have weapons they can just tag us
with lasers and put onboard AI on these
drones they can swarm our Pilots or our
drones and tell us what we're doing
wrong and how to get better at fighting
drone swarms I wanna decides what's
wrong real real quick AI will give us
the algorithm I want to give a shout out
to rsbn uh I'm not going to use CNN or
Fox News or any of these other news
sources for the coverage of Donald
Trump's speech we're going to be using
right side broadcasting network nice
yeah because they're better and I would
just say you guys should consider
supporting them for their coverage of
what's going on I wouldn't say that for
any other news source that we we cited
for commentary or anything like that but
I like rsbn and I am grateful that
they're there on the ground to capture
Donald Trump giving the speech and then
we can provide commentary to you guys so
special shout out I don't know anybody
over there but they do good work so
we're just going to be waiting watching
their stream on Rumble and then when
Trump does arrive which should be any
moment now we'll uh we'll we'll play
he's always late though I know I know I
know so we're chilling we're hanging out
for now and uh wondering whether or not
the Deep state will hear the pleas of
Ian they hear it thank you guys hear me
um I I think we can regrow the coral
reefs with micro fragmentation we can
regrow the fish population by
introducing iron dust into the ocean and
fertilizing the Plankton we can uh pull
the carbon out of the air and start a
re-industrialization of graphene all the
tools are within our reach but we need
organization we need to calm people down
he's doing all that and I'm just trying
to keep my kids off Tick Tock like and
not be and we can free the sources
so I also want to mention as we're
waiting maybe we'll get into this after
Trump speech but the the U.S dollar is
trending
and Saudi Arabia is working deals to
restructure its trade agreements
Brazil and China are going to be trading
in one I mean the U.S dollar may be
about to collapse I think gold gold is
skyrocketing what's gold currently at
I don't know but maybe skyrocketing is
the wrong uh wrong way to describe it
wasn't like Doge just going up yesterday
yeah
Elon was screwing that that's because
he put the Doge
it was great it's a good time
yeah gold and silver are up
I mean look it now this is like
this is probably the the most
significant 2031 Silver's at 25. wow
this is the most significant uh
development regarding the currency
probably in my lifetime uh you know and
like it's possible that the the value of
the dollar significantly goes down yeah
it's possible that the value of most of
the world's Fiat currencies go down
um you know you look at the value of one
like Yuan compared to the value of one
dollar uh there's there's not any reason
to believe that the value of the dollar
couldn't be half that means half of what
whatever money you have in the bank can
get half of what you can get now it's
like and people don't realize this
because labor is the is one of the
biggest costs of any business and so so
so labor costs are not going to be the
same as the cost of a carton eggs
meaning you know running a business you
will have employees who are like hey I
need more money you're thinking about
what how much money can I give to a
person in exchange for labor or a
service that won't go up as fast it will
go up though but what's going to happen
is the cost of the hard raw material in
the food products become harder and
harder to source as labor costs increase
every step of the way there's an
increase in the in the cost because of
the The Profit needs of each industry or
I should say the the the basic income
requirements so first you got to hire a
guy to to you know pick the strawberries
or whatever then you got to hire guy to
package of strawberries and because each
of those person needs a little bit more
money that's what's going to lead to
this hyperinflation runaway train we
have some action going on here I don't
know what's going on but uh
Here Comes Eric Trump and Lara Trump
followed up by
Stephen Miller
followed out by Dan's Covina that's
Jason Miller
I would imagine that I just called Jason
Stephen
we are now getting in to a very intimate
time where the president might walk out
but going back to censorship so we're
all right we'll just we'll just keep it
on standby until Trump arrives but it
looks like he may be here any second now
yep is that
is he coming in
they're zooming in
don't know just yet but we'll uh once
Trump's remarks start I don't want I'm
not trying to piggyback off rspn's
commentary but I want to give them a
shout out and hope that you guys
consider supporting them you know
typically if we're doing like a
commentary stuff we'll pull up like CNN
or whatever and it's like thanks for the
you know news pool but I don't like you
RSB and I like so
it makes sense shout out shout out I'm
glad I think that do you think that our
dollar would be in Jeopardy if Trump was
the president rather than Biden no I
don't either yeah definitely not it
would be stronger and I don't understand
why the left doesn't get that or maybe
they just don't want to understand the
left doesn't care yeah they don't
they're it's short it's short-term gain
it's it's
emotional satisfaction there's no logic
there's no structure these are people
that would burn down their own houses to
to own the cons I always say like Trump
derangement syndrome like saying that is
cringe but it's legit real like it it it
does exist you're right before you're
100 right there is a lot of people with
Trump derangements syndrome there are a
lot of people that are just like oh
Trump deserves all this I think he's
walking in he's coming in we'll lifting
their cameras
[Music]
I'm so bad for him
no I'll just because I want to get it as
soon as Trump starts speaking okay there
are some people that are ideologically
motivated that that really want to see
the living standard of the United States
to to go down because the living
standard of other countries and and the
people in other countries needs to go up
and it can't it can't you can't have the
U.S with such a high living standard in
the rest of the Trump's looking good
have you seen the pig I saw the picture
of him when he was going in and waving
his belly's gone way down oh he's
definitely like working out or doing
something yeah maybe he's on that
ozempic stuff I don't know
he's thinned up a bit did you see that
Lloyd Dreyfus is joining the global
green Merchants Exodus from Russia and
like that's supposed they'll stop
exporting Russian Green from like July 1
which will no one's doing any of that
it's going to increase Global food cause
it's suffering it's true though it's
Reuters put it out so it's Reuters okay
what was the the yo people who live in
cities are going to regret it very soon
hold on if they don't already I do I the
summer of
11 school I would ever be in a city why
would you want your kids to go to those
schools they don't go to that kind of
school they go to a Christian classical
school well listen I don't trust them oh
no no it's very regimented like when
when the pandemic like it all hit they
were like absolutely not we don't
believe a mess don't they sent letters
home saying do not pay attention to what
they say on television they're only
meant to scare you we didn't have to
mask up like yeah
I think you you should still consider
getting away from oh I definitely yeah
I'm gonna come down here with you Tim
yeah we'll come down you know we're
we're getting everybody away from the
city because West Virginia's best
Virginia and people here are based
ranked number one for Republican like
friendliness towards Republicans and all
of the states my country second most
Trump supporting State yep so it's not
just conservative it's it's a lot of
regular people who don't really care
about politics but care enough to know
how bad it is
you know you have in these cities people
who quote and quote care about politics
but only insofar as they are told to and
they just March in lockstep with a
zombie horde so yeah they talk a lot
about it but don't really exercise their
rights that much I've noticed that
living in the city for 20 years
here's Trump there we go
obligatory yeah
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody we have to
save our country
God bless you all God bless you all
and I never thought anything like this
could happen in America never thought it
could happen
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it
from the beginning the Democrats
spied in my campaign remember that
we're all not ignored the attack with an
onslaught of fraudulent investigations
Russia Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two the illegal and
unconstitutional raid on Mar-A-Lago
right here
foreign
to the fisa courts
the FBI and doj relentlessly pursuing
Republicans
the unconstitutional changes to election
laws by not getting approvals from state
legislators
the millions of votes illegally stuffed
into ballot boxes and all caught on
government cameras obligatory we here at
timcast disagree with Trump's claims on
the election but we'll let them continue
in order not to say anything bad about
the hunter Biden laptop from him oh yeah
which exposes the Biden family as
criminals in which
according to the pollsters would have
made a 17 point difference
in the election result
and we needed a lot less than that like
about 16.9
it would have been in our favor not my
favor our favor because our country is
going to hell
do we remember the 51 intelligence
agents
who said Hunter Biden's laptop was
Russian disinformation
it didn't exist it was Russian
disinformation remember that
and that was all confirmed strongly by
the FBI
when they all knew that it wasn't
Russian disinformation
and so much more our elections were like
those of a third world country
and now this massive election
interference at a scale never seen
before in our country
beginning with the radical left to
George Soros back prosecutor Alvin Bragg
of New York
[Applause]
he would get president Trump I gotta get
him I'm gonna get him this is a guy
campaigning
you want to get president Trump at any
cost and this before he knew anything
about me didn't know a thing about me he
was campaigning
as it turns out virtually everybody that
has looked at this case including rhinos
and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime he's right that it
should never have been brought
never
everybody yeah
even people that
aren't big fans have said it they said
this is not the right thing to do
it's an insult to our country as the
world is already laughing at us for so
many other reasons like our open borders
are incompetent withdrawal from
Afghanistan Where We Left Behind
American citizens 85 billion dollars
worth of
the best military equipment in the world
lost 13 magnificent young lives and far
too many
to mention that are so badly hurt with
the loss of arms and legs and facial
obliteration
the most embarrassing time in our
country's history in my opinion
then our give up on energy Independence
and even energy dominant we're going to
be dominant within six months more than
any other Nation times two
we had this all just three years ago our
raging
crime statistics if you look in
democrat-run cities numbers the likes of
which we have never seen before you know
Trump crushed the open Trump's countries
nuclear weapons so we never mentioned or
discussed we're connected already but
I'm trying to open another one I can't
people I'm seeing on Twitter people
saying that Trump has overloaded
rumble.com Administration on leadership
yeah to an all-out nuclear World War
Three Can Happen God we're not very far
away from it believe it or not
an economy that has been crippled by the
biggest inflation we have seen in more
than 60 years
and a military that I use to defeat Isis
in four weeks they said it would take
four years
four weeks
to kill al-baghdadi and solomonie
wow that has now gone woke at the top
Levels by trying to indoctrinate
everyone down to the lowest ranking
Patriot
but now they have really stepped up
their reference by
indicting
the 45th president
of the United States who received
[Applause]
and the Republican front runner yep 75
million votes which is more than any
sitting president in the history of our
country
[Applause]
wow and in the wings they've got a local
racist Democrat district attorney in
Atlanta who is doing everything in her
power to indict me over an absolutely
perfect phone call even more perfect
than the one I made with the president
of Ukraine remember a kid kept saying
that's a perfect call
this one was more perfect I wish he knew
what perfect means you shouldn't say
that many people on the phone
or hung up and discussed because of
something I inappropriately said
because nothing was said wrong in fact
at the end of the call we agreed to
continue our conversation about election
fraud
and election fraud specifically in
Georgia
at a later time many people on the phone
including lots of lawyers nobody found
anything wrong with that perfect call
until a book promotion tour
many months later all of a sudden they
say you know I remember Trump making a
call
to interfere with the upcoming 2024
election
and it should be dropped immediately
immediately
[Applause]
hands down
what what they accuse Trump of doing
they're literally doing right now in
front of us then you have a radical left
lunatic known as a bomb thrower
who is harassing hundreds of my people
day after day
over the boxes hoax you know the boxes
hooks as we call it just so everyone
knows I come under what's known as the
presidential records act which was
designed and approved by Congress long
ago just for this reason
under the ACT I'm supposed to negotiate
with Nara the National Archives and
Records Administration
which as of this date is a radical left
trouble making organization that red
flags the Constitution of the United
States and the Bill of Rights is
dangerous
and triggering can you imagine this is
what we have to deal with
but there is no criminality under the
presidential records Act
that is not what it's all about we were
negotiating in very
good faith proper way in order to return
some or all of the documents that I
openly and in very plain sight
brought with me to Mar-A-Lago from our
beautiful white house just as virtually
every other president has done in the
past
when FBI and doj officials with Nara
away
here I told my lawyer to show them the
very secure storage room
in which they were locked
the FBI cell request in writing was
could you please put another lock on the
door we immediately complied brevity is
not his gift it's a lot different than
the Biden situation isn't it
the next thing I know we were rated by
many gun toting FBI agents
who took whatever they wanted including
my passports and medical records
just the fact everybody
can't even believe it who would think
that that could happen today
next up will be the DC indictment
because our Justice what he's talking
about right now has become Lawless
they're using it now in addition to
everything else to win elections
apparently they're not looking at me
through the view of the non-criminal
presidential records act they came up
with a new one this is a new one
and they're looking at me through the
Espionage Act think of that how does
that sound of 1917 where the penalty
is death
even though that has absolutely nothing
to do with openly taking boxes of
documents and mostly clothing and other
things to my home
which President Obama has done the
bushes have done Jimmy Carter's done
Ronald Reagan is done there are at least
a handful of people that everybody
Hillary Clinton get rid of the dirty
things
that was okay
but nobody's done it like Joe Biden
this lunatic special prosecutor named
Jack Smith I wonder what it was prior to
a change
foreign
he is even worse than they are
is only looking at Trump yet Joe Biden
took massive amounts more documents even
removed many boxes to Chinatown
you believe that she's got 10 million
dollars from China where did that come
from I guess they were banking on
Hunter's expertise
and had others stored in unsecured
offices in Pennsylvania and strewn all
over his garage floor where his now very
famous Corvette
is also stored
all over the floor including classified
documents
but that's okay
perhaps most importantly he has
1850 boxes in Delaware
which he is refusing to give up
but isn't that real obstruction that's
obstruction as president I have the
right to declassify documents and the
process is automatic
if I take them with me it's automatic
declassify
Biden was vice president
he had absolutely no right to declassify
as vice president
he doesn't come under the non-criminal
presidential records act he comes under
the very criminal Federal records act
unfortunately for him but it's not going
to matter because they don't follow the
law
which has very severe penalties
he had classified documents that he took
while he was a senator
which is absolutely inexcusable and
other Senators including Democrats
are outraged
but he's not being harassed and hounded
like the people
who work for me are
in fact they seem to have forgotten
about his documents entirely so many
thousands and thousands okay with him
they like to say that I'm obstructing
which I'm not
because I was working with Nara very
nicely until the raid on my home
but Biden is obstructing by making it
impossible to get the 1850 boxes or
explain why many documents were located
in Chinatown can't explain it why were
they in China Town I don't know
we're going to switch to uh this one
here
assuming it's working
never ran for office I will get him
her name is Leticia James
Donald Trump's official Rumble and she
proclaimed while campaigning quote I
look forward to going into the Office of
the Attorney General every single day
suing him and then going home
before she knew me
she announced what is fueling my soul
right now is Trump
and that she had her eyes on Trump Tower
those eyes are focused on Trump town
didn't know the young lady
she even assured her supporters in an
election promise that we're going to
definitely sue him we're going to be a
real pain in the ass
he's going to know my name personally
and then she claimed that I was an
illegitimate president I think you ever
think of that with all
with all we did with all we did on
energy with all we did on the military
on taxes biggest tax cuts in history the
swamp biggest regulation Cuts in history
right to try
people able to get drugs now that aren't
approved
hopefully you don't have that problem
Leticia James vowed to use every area of
the law to quote investigate president
Trump and his business transactions
those transactions are going to be
investigated she said
and that of her family
and his family
because we're going after his family and
we're going after them hard
this is all before entering office and
all before knowing anything at all about
me but you're gonna get me
this is why along with unrelenting crime
so many people and companies are leaving
New York
she said that I falsified my financial
statements but in fact we're proving and
we'll prove that my financial statements
were substantially more than we
submitted not less
and in all cases have a strong
disclaimer clause in them which tells
the institutions that may look at that
if they want to
not to rely on the statement
but they've got a problem with their
case because number one I'm
very under leverage they can't believe
it all the stuff they read and gave
and have very little debt relative to
the value of assets and importantly not
One bank has lost even one dollar she
was investigating me to save Banks
they're very good lawyers
but they didn't lose a dollar with us
during this period of time
in fact the banks were talking about
made almost 200 million dollars off
Donald Trump
and they like me very much
we never missed a payment never got a
default notice had a great relationship
with all of them I don't need Banks we
have a lot of cash
I built a great business with my family
built a fantastic business
thank you
I have a son here who's done a great job
and I have another son here who's done a
great job
the Tiffany
and Ivanka and baron will be great
someday he's tall he is tall and he's
smart but I have a great family and
they've done a fantastic job and we
appreciate it very much they've gone
through hell
so she's suing me over banks that
weren't defrauded when she should be
focused on violent crime that's driving
people out of the state
this is a persecution not an
investigation she's put our family
through hell it's cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to defend
but our heads are held very very high
they want to settle the case but I want
no part of that
so here we are now
it's where we were today
in a city that was
so gracious four or five years ago
but now we're there spend time there
today as you possibly read
with a local failed district attorney
charging a former president of the
United States for the first time in
history
on a basis that every single pundit and
legal analyst said there is no case
there's no case they kept saying there's
no case
but that doesn't matter virtually
everyone
but it's far worse than that because he
knew there was no case
that's why last week he delayed for a
month and then immediately took that
back and through this ridiculous
indictment together came out today
everybody said this is not really an
indictment there's nothing here
my lawyers came to me and they said
there's nothing here they're not even
saying what you did
the criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive
amounts of grand jury information
for which he should be prosecuted
or at a minimum he should resign
and Alvin Bragg's wife confirmed a
report that claimed her husband has
Trump nailed on felonies
she has since locked down her Twitter
account
his chief
his chief firm run by Chuck Schumer's
brother Robert
he quit the firm in order to go to work
in the D.A office in order to get Trump
can you imagine that Hillary Clinton
Democrat lawyer Democrat firm ultimately
quit as she prosecuted because Bragg
didn't you thank you for the case think
of the same guy that brought this
ridiculous thing today
yet during his investigation this
prosecutor named Mark pomerantz wrote
and published a book
saying also it's a privileged things and
has been very strongly
reprimanded he was reprimanded so
strongly I've never seen anything like
it that's probably the end of it
but
what he did was probably very illegal
but he was very very strongly
reprimanded
even district attorney Bragg was furious
with him they were having a tremendous
fight in the office because of it
but hope is never lost because various
prosecutors in the DA's office also quit
because they thought president Trump was
being treated very unfairly how about
that isn't that great oh I love them I'd
like to meet them I'd like to meet them
the DA's office
even had a web page
meet the team of Executives who have
done this to president Trump that was
the title isn't that nice they
immediately had to take it down
meanwhile overall crime in New York was
up 30 percent last year
much more than that the year before with
felony assaults robberies and burglaries
all up by massive massive numbers
not the same place that I know not the
same place that you know
and this is where we are right now I
have a trump-hating judge
with a trump-hating wife and family
whose daughter worked for Kamala Harris
and now receives money from the Biden
Harris campaign and a lot of it yeah
we recently had another trial and the
same judge told the fine man who worked
for me for many many years you're
actually eating a Lunchable that if you
admit your guild
but if you don't yeah you're serious wow
if we go through a trial and you're
found guilty you're going away for 10
years and maybe imagine the seed oils
which for a 75 year old man with a great
family
really means life
what the prosecutors and judge did to
that man I will never forget
because it's right out of the old Soviet
Union that's where we are
they said you say anything about Trump
meaning that's bad
and you won't even have to serve the 90
days you'll walk free
and they say that to many of my
employees
we have this Jack Smith lunatic
threatening people every single day
through his Representatives
they're threatening jail terms
but talk about Trump and you'll go free
this is where we are as a nation who
would have thought they can't beat us at
The Ballot Box so they try and beat us
through the law
that's the country in which we live
however right now the USA is a mess
our economy is crashing inflation is out
of control Russia has joined with China
can you believe that
Saudi Arabia has joined with Iran
China Russia Iran and North Korea have
formed together
is a menacing and destructive Coalition
would have never happened
if I were your president would never
have happened nor would Russia attacking
Ukraine have happened all of those lives
would be saved all of those beautiful
cities would be standing
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard
which will be our greatest defeat
frankly in 200 years there will be no
defeat like that
that will take us away from being even a
great power
if you took the five worst Presidents in
the history of the United States
and added them up they would not have
done near the destruction to our country
as Joe Biden and the Biden
Administration have done
incredibly we are now a failing Nation
we are a nation in Decline
and now these radical left lunatics want
to interfere with our elections by using
law enforcement
we can't let that happen
[Applause]
with all of this being said
and with a very dark cloud
over our Beloved Country
I have no doubt nevertheless
that we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you and
God bless America thank you very much
everybody thank you
Phil has been replaced by a Post-It note
reading Trump is right about all of this
by accurate uh we can we'll wrap up
Trump's Rumble there uh yeah man he's
right about everything someone super
chatted
that Putin just became the president of
the U.N security Council yeah that was
the other day Russia will be leading the
U.N security Council this month
so there it is man the country just
invaded its neighbor
and it's leading and you know I know
that people are going to have opinions
on whether or not you know it was
justified or whatever but leading the
the U.N security Council
and they are a belligerent in a war
that could possibly lead to a total
nuclear war Global nuclear war a
thermonuclear exchange between you know
and they're leaving the uh the security
Council that's I feel secure I I decided
I feel secure that was the council's
purpose they did their job I how would
they vote him in it says here Ukraine
was uh urging members to block but I
mean honestly the council probably is
more secure with having at least United
States Russia or China at the head at
the moment
the council itself I don't know if the
world's more secure but the council the
U.N is more secure as an organization
with a Powerhouse at the head let's
let's elaborate on something that Donald
Trump was talking about we got the story
from Forbes
from a couple days ago
who wants to read that headline could
the US dollar collapse Donald Trump was
talking about this in his speech as they
are throwing everything at him to
destroy him possibly the only person who
can salvage the United States economy
and World standing Donald Trump they are
trying to stop
and if you look at how the bidens are
handling business dealings it makes a
lot of sense
if I had a bunch of money invested in
China I do not want the us to win right
a bet on China is a bet on China if
Donald Trump gets an office and the U.S
becomes great again and the dollar
becomes stronger and the economy
improves all of those foreign
investments take a hit
the incentive of these people if they're
investing in China
is to see the United States falter but
there are opportunities for uh the u.s's
Improvement to actually improve China
and vice versa that's where the value of
trade
it's very odd but at this point what are
we going to do about it like that's what
he said he's like you know we need to
stop this hell there's no mechanism for
us to stop any of this what particularly
stopwatch particularly like any of this
from happening like him you know them
stopping him him being indicted uh I I
feel like it's dominoes falling over
yeah I mean it is that's it it's a
runaway train it's like a commercial
yeah there's an inertia in motion right
now but that's only going to continue if
no force is acted upon it so we can
change the momentum who's we and how
every human that has a camera on the
internet can can alter the fate of
humanity right now but but I mean that's
Ian big statement with with not a whole
lot of substance I'm not sure what and
when half the people think Trump should
be in prison I don't see how what you're
just you're encouraging does anything
I feel like sad because it does do stuff
but if you guys don't see it I mean I
can't make it no I I can see how like a
large you know if everybody with cameras
did their thing but you have to remember
that most people like the majority of
people don't even aren't even paying
attention to this right now right like
my friends who are taking their three
kids to school every day they're not
watching this they barely know what's
going on all they know is that he paid a
hooker and it's illegal like that's
literally all they know and so they
don't care they don't care and the media
it for the five minutes if they tune in
right before dinner is only going to
tell them one side of their story and
our message is really never getting out
unless it's to people who are heavily
invested in politics which isn't a ton
of people Stormy Daniels is a hooker
isn't she I mean technically I got
trouble on that for on Twitter I got
suspended for two weeks on Twitter for
calling her and is the exactly the word
that starts with a w and ends with an E
so I'm gonna be but I mean that as like
a scientific and academic term no
actually she is a woman who is paid to
have sex with men she sells her body for
money and she's very proud
for free is that what happened is that
why
I get apparently he like was like
flirting with her at a golf game I think
it was some had something to do with the
art of the deal and uh you know he
talked her down to a freebie let me try
it before I buy it otherwise I might
want to return it oh and she was just
like all right you get one freebie and
then he was like don't tell anybody
listen I think those type of women are
gross anyway but like she is extra gross
she was today she was talking on her
Twitter about people like like enter DMS
and stuff calling her like a
dumpster right like I'm trying not to be
whatever and she's like that is great
like I would rather be that than
arrested and like she like these people
are insane like she really thinks that
like her lifestyle well I always I just
want to point out it's funny how we can
segue from ladies and gentlemen
the country is collapsing I'm sorry the
dollar is failing I'm just so sick of
these your livelihood is at stake but
let's talk about this hooker well I mean
a lot of this happened because of
feminism and women taking over and and
all those type of things and she is just
and more of that she's more of that like
women being empowered by their own body
right she is an extension of that if we
didn't have the the feminist movement or
even like the Civil Rights the way they
codified you know fit certain things
into law we wouldn't be here right now
that we would not be like this and our
society wouldn't certainly wouldn't be
hyper sexualized and over sexualized and
I wouldn't be worried about my kids you
know having to see degenerate stuff in
the middle of the street though I don't
care what it is it's all degenerate and
listen we wouldn't have that much we
wouldn't have that much degeneracy if if
men were men and women were women and
women stayed home with kids and paid
attention to them and did the right
thing and kept them off Tick-Tock and
stuff like do your job is this another
repeal the 19th thing listen I would I'm
not saying to repeal the 19th but I
would happily give up my right to vote
if these liberal women stopped voting
100 if that was the deal you could have
would you give it up forever yeah
forever I mean I would give up I don't
even think women should really I mean
I'm here because of the necessity right
like you know we need to live in a two
income household and I kind of resent
that like if I'm gonna do a job yeah
fine I'll be good at it I do a little
bit yeah you don't need to limit two
income household
I have to you just need a good
breadwinner
okay but like
not everybody has the opportunity to get
a good Breadwinner okay don't sell
yourself short I'm not saying that but
but the point is it's like if I forced a
work which I in my situation am right
I'm gonna definitely be good at what I
do because I want to secure you know
things for my children but like I
definitely resent that I resent that
we're in this type of culture where like
I have to work so it's it's annoys me
but I I blame really I I blame women for
a lot actually probably everything
that's the nature of uh progressivism in
this country is that
uh
what starts with tolerance becomes
acceptance becomes requirement
and celebration at first it was like
women want to work oh no we can't have
that and then eventually people were
like look if a woman wants to work just
let her work okay if she can do the job
she can do the job
then that was tolerance people people
tolerated women having jobs in some
places then it became outright
acceptance where all of a sudden you're
now seeing women being encouraged like
this is a normal thing now women should
work and then once all women were
working it's a requirement women have to
work now I was talking no longer a
choice I was doing a podcast today
talking to a buddy of mine and uh we
were talking about
um the way that oh I don't know I just
had a brain fart I totally lost what I
was going to say it happens to me all
the time like they're talking about
women yeah yeah you were talking women
okay so yeah I'm not sure where I was
going with that podcast I apologize
it's gone you might come back later but
something about repealing the 19th I
think is that I mean that's a great idea
no I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
it's always the men who are like don't
do it and the women who are like yes you
know he's like he's like I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding but are you but
are you really honestly honestly I'm I'm
a I'm a my personal opinion is is
democracy is not all that great
I take a more gender I ideological view
of voting and I think it shouldn't be
about men and women it should be about
your level of testosterone so if you
have a certain level of testosterone
above a number then you can vote yeah
you can only vote I mean I definitely
think that there should be some limits
to voting oh like I think that there
should be there are limits there are
limitations departments okay like
literacy requirements um I think that
there should be comprehension uh
requirements most people they read like
those um you know like the extra
measures on the balance and they don't
even know what they mean they have no
idea they're just checking boxes right
yeah not only that like you should be
invested somewhat in your community that
own property own land I'm sorry like
they're it's not a freebie like
everybody wants everything handed to
them in this life like it's not no the
idea that the right to vote uh doesn't
come along with some kind of
responsibility is a problem everyone's a
very very keen on talking about their
rights and that they have the right to
this and that
um rights come with responsibilities
there attached they're part of the right
you have responsibilities that are
literally ingrained in having the right
so if you have the right to own property
that means that you you are responsible
for that property you don't have the
right to take something else from
someone else you know you you have the
responsibility to get along with your
your you know your community and stuff
like that because you're free people
have the responsibility to behave in a
responsible manner in a way that works
with their community and stuff like that
but people are taking it too far like
they're taking the right to own property
as like the right like the right to own
it to work to own it right to someone
right to have property like that's
that's what I mean that's with
everything and that's why they can get
away with half the stuff right they're
like we are morally virtuous and
Superior and Trump's Hitler and so
therefore we can do whatever we want and
it's completely Justified because it's
what I want that's what my feelings tell
me to do yeah there's there's no there's
we've lost I don't I don't I don't see
I've been saying this non-stop for years
but I do not see based on the paths that
we are on
any point at which in the near future
there's unification I don't either and
it's and and I feel like the more this
stuff happens the more it becomes clear
to other people what is happening people
love to complain and people love to to
poo poo the idea of any kind of civil
conflict and stuff like that but when
you tell them point to the off ramp
right so maybe it's not in the next two
three five ten years but tell me what
happens that makes the people that that
are on the left and the people on the
right agree to some way
I do have a vision of a future with a
non-violent resolution and that is
Donald Trump wins in 2024
he then immediately brings some better
people into doj a good AG indictments
are issued for corrupt Democrats the
people who pushed impeachment all these
other hoaxes are indicted tried and
charged the left loses their minds there
will be riotous moments but it won't
reach that level of total
destabilization we will then see some
degree of accountability and then from
there it will push out the corrupt left
and limit their ability to move forward
that along with people having kids
homeschooling them getting away from
cities is going to start Paving a future
route where the left becomes
marginalized I think right now the
Divide is just too great for that I mean
I used to be like that Arthur Brooks
conservative Heart Like Republican like
oh we just need to be nice to them and
you know show our empathy and get that
and I am not that way now if you are on
the side that is weaponizing our justice
system and thinks it's okay and you are
on the side that are sexualizing my
children you are my enemy like literally
my enemy well I'm protecting my you're
my enemy I agree but what I'm saying is
if Trump wins in 2024 and immediately
begin it gets an AG who starts the
indictment process I think that will
marginalize the left
Trump's re-election in 2024 will strip
them of their abilities to do things
like they're doing now and it will
increasingly marginalize them their
propensity for sterilizing their kids
and aborting their own children combined
with conservatives having kids and
homeschooling them will mean that the
left will slowly be pushed out will get
smaller as time goes on imagine it like
this you got the left and the right the
left will get smaller as the right gets
bigger and then eventually they'll just
cease to exist and the future will just
become more populist pro-america it
starts with Donald Trump getting
reelected in 2024. yeah but do you think
that's a possibility oh yeah absolutely
I don't you don't think Trump can get
reelected I I think I love Trump and
that's who I want I want him more than I
want DeSantis or anybody else but I
think that the majority of it's about
it's ballot harvesting in ballot chasing
and yeah but we're not doing that we
don't have that right we don't have the
ground game like they do but who managed
to get it together but we do we're not
getting together the story is Orange
County traditionally conservative
introduces Universal male voting ballot
harvesting ghost Democrat Republicans
say hey wait a minute boom Republican
again you're asking a lot of the The
Establishment people that are already in
there think about it like how many
wrestlers do we know that's the only
person that's doing this you know what I
mean like we need like 70 more Scott
Presley without it it's way it's wicked
Bleak that's what I'm saying we got we
got at least 70 Scott pressler's
listening right now I hope okay Scott
pressler's I love you keep it up yeah
speaking of Scott Pressler there's a
really important election going on in
Wisconsin
is that what this is today are the polls
Wisconsin Supreme Court vote April 4th I
don't even know if the polls are still
open but they said make a noise about it
Scott I'm doing it on the show a lot of
people have been talking about making
noise about this election in Wisconsin
it pulls I don't know if they're open
all day I don't know but if you're able
to vote vote if you're in Wisconsin you
want to vote for your Supreme Court
Justice I think anybody listening who
wants to make sure we win just needs to
reach out to Scott Pressler and he's a
leader in this regard registering voters
leading the charge on ballot chasing and
where it's where it's legal ballot
harvesting and if you want to figure out
where to get started how to get started
he's your guy and he's so friendly like
he will answer anybody like he's the
nicest person to so yeah so I'm I I
don't know I'm fairly confident I think
if the election was held today Trump
would win
the polls say otherwise but I don't the
polls have always been wrong they're
wrong about everything I mean if there's
no
election Shenanigans right well maybe
but but here's the issue
Republicans need to get on their ground
game absolutely the activism the
knocking on doors the chasing and the
harvesting but right now
the economy is trash
people are angry and they're angry with
Joe Biden
and I was telling the story about how it
was at the casino last weekend and the
guy sitting next to me said he thought
the j6er should be executed he also said
Joe Biden is has destroyed the dollar
it's worthless and he keeps sending our
money overseas so this guy clearly hates
Joe Biden yeah would he vote for Trump
he wouldn't vote
he's the kind of guy who abstains but
this is the kind of or he's a he's a
Suburban uh liberal Indian guy who hates
Donald Trump absolutely hates Joe Biden
now but that's not going to help us like
guys like him are not helping anything
to tell them Democrats were able to win
without harvesting but it was also
because everything was locked down there
was no Sports no movies nothing to do
and then they went ballot harvesting
they do not have that if next year we
get like h5n1 bird flu or whatever and
everything's locked down again maybe but
Biden can't do it twice the first time
you fool me you know fool me one shame
on you fool me twice shame on me
for me for me a third time you're not
going to phone me a third time all right
George Bush there won't be there won't
be enthusiasm for him like people will
not turn out for him that's probably I
guess no one turned out for Joe Biden no
true 12 million new voters turned out
for Donald Trump what Joe Biden got was
not turnout but but returns he got
returns not turnout returns and that was
when a universal Melon vote was sent to
someone's house it got returned because
the Democrats knew it doesn't matter
what the sentiment of the population is
it matters how many of these pieces of
paper in that box so I guarantee you you
got some guy knocking the door can I
what can I help you with something uh
have you filled out your ballot no okay
go don't come back look at I'm gonna
come back every day until I see you put
that in your mailbox okay fine whatever
here Biden get out of here what's in the
mailbox I had multiple ones sent to my
apartment and I I did absentee ballot
but that's the other thing too with with
the mail-in ballots when you separate
that outer envelope from the inner they
put them in two separate piles you're
never going to be able to match them up
again too so it's absolutely almost
impossible if it's mail-in balance to
tell us about eligible at once or not
I'm not even concerned about that
because I I I I think Democrats are that
crazy they get three balances of their
house they're filling them all out and
putting cents 100 sure maybe but I mean
it is a lot harder what I'm more
concerned with is just outright ballot
harvesting yeah like
you send a vote to every single person's
house the return rate's going to be
massive then you get very LAX signature
verification and that's all you need we
don't need to argue anything else so
Carrie Lakes moves to to check
signatures is brilliant because the
reality is a bunch of these ballots are
legitimate and got returned but probably
should be disqualified because they're
improperly filled out and can't be
securely verified
a lot of them are probably not good
which is why signature verification
exists right if this is the funny thing
they say that it's impossible for there
to be like oh there's no fraud okay Bill
Barr said there was fraud was there a
substantial amount that altered the
outcome of the election he said no the
issue is
with Carrie Lakes election there was
what 17 000 votes okay well now we got a
problem because we're talking about a
very small amount of errors and
malfeasance that could cause an election
to swing as it pertains to Donald Trump
in 2024 they're not going to have the
lockdowns they're not going to have the
political fervor they may try and
generate it with stories like this the
goal of this prosecution may be to get
Trump in the news and once again berate
regular people over the head and tell
them Trump's a criminal because they
want Trump in the news
they may backfire on them though because
they don't have covid this time to lock
people down take away what they love and
force them into a political world but
there are a lot of people and I know
this like from people in my own family
who were like Trump since he came down
the stairs they are really tired of
constant drama like they are they're
like listen if I I love him and I think
he's going to do a great job but if it
cost me all this and I don't feel that
way I want him to go in second term and
like burn everything I think he would be
on the biggest revenge tour ever and I
think it would be epic so I'm 100 there
for that but there are regular everyday
people that are tired that are tired of
all this I'm with you like I'm if he
wants to exact Justice legally then
whatever but don't just complain for 18
months about it don't be like the
radical left and that guy and that guy
like I was like nodding off like get I
get it do what you got to do when you
get there dude but you don't need to
convince us well he probably still needs
to convince some people give me a vision
of of goodness that's going to come out
of this and maybe you'll convince me
well it's hard to see a lot of visions
of goodness coming out of this I mean
they set the president what I think we
should do right now is I think that
McCarthy should start doing hearings on
um Hunter Biden and the laptop and Biden
himself and how he was corrupt right
like it well anything they can and then
I think all of the DA's anything at all
and all of the DA's should start looking
at every Democrat within their state to
do the same thing here's the deal right
like we they're already playing unfair
it's time for us to play unfair what
they did was they were like find me the
guy and I'll find you the crime do the
same thing now do it now we have this
story from timcast.com
Kevin McCarthy says Congress will hold
D.A Bragg accountable get him the D.A is
attempting to interfere in our
Democratic process by invoking federal
law to bring politicized charges against
President Trump
he cited politicized charges by the New
York D.A in a statement
uh Bragg is Bragg's weaponization of the
federal Justice process will be held
accountable by Congress all right well
you know I'm not going to hold my breath
for Kevin McCarthy or anything like that
but we'll maybe we'll see something the
problem is they don't have any authority
to put anybody in jail so we can expose
all this stuff and but the D.A I mean
not the D.A the the justice system the
doj is not going to do anything with any
of the findings I mean we see that all
the time all they have is subpoena power
and even when they have subpoena power
they will not enforce it they will not
say oh you you recalled you didn't
testify or you lied how many people do
you see all the time testifying hearings
that lie under oath to Congress which is
a jailable offense and nothing happens
to them so there is no accountability
when it comes to Congress other than a
fact-finding missions which everybody
seems to politicize anyway but I still
think it needs to be done but I really
think all the all the Republican DA's in
this country need to get their busting
gear for sure I agree 100 the more that
the Republicans and conservatives can
use the government to attack their
opponents do it do it it's on it's
already hit it they already yeah do it
hearings subpoenas do it all of it
punish them punish them
I think that's a that's that's a bad way
to think about it
Republicans for the longest time have
been spineless and cowardly there's not
we don't need to punish anybody we need
the law we need them to be like we're
just gonna do the bare minimum of law
enforcement Hunter Biden bare minimum
special prosecutor it's law fair tie
them up in hearings but it's not it's
not even this is the problem if if the
rights view of standard law enforcement
is a special circumstance in which we
get revenge this is why Republicans
never go after Democrats when they break
the law
it's like well Barack Obama murdered a
16 year old but because I don't want
revenge we're gonna let it slide
so this idea that we have to get revenge
on them I don't care about revenge I
just want Justice one time I want to see
Barack Obama in handcuffs being brought
into a criminal court for the murder of
Abdul Rahman al-alalaki instead Donald
Trump paid a hooker and that's what the
the spectacle is so they would have
gotten him for jaywalking like like
that's where it really is that they had
that when you entered the courthouse Mr
Mr former president UJ walked I mean I'm
just saying like Republicans don't do
anything this is the time that they need
to get on it they they need to get their
button here but what's going to motivate
them because they know that the voters
are still going to vote for them right
like that's their incentive is are they
going to be re-elected there's no
incentive for them to go harder than it
is other than our country failing but
there's what a handful maybe three or
four that we like that have a backbone
like that
cowards they're cow they're they're so
few conservatives that will do anything
they they absolutely should do I think
that they should use every means the
that the law allows to go after their
political opponents for every single
violation if they have if they yeah
think about what the logic of that
statement is we let them break the law
that's that's what it sounds like you're
saying no no I'm saying I'm saying we're
doing that now go after them for every
violation of the law the government
right but it's not punishment it's not
Revenge it's not just accountability
it's just the standard process of law
enforcement it's been ignored by the
Republicans absolutely and and they have
re ignored it they've been ignoring it
Donald Trump himself ignored the law
he's allowed so what we should have a uh
it's like this it's like uh when when
the Democrats say high capacity magazine
and they refer to anything above 10 10
Rounds despite the fact that rifles come
with 30 round magazines as standard
when we say like we want we want revenge
we want punishment we want you know go
after them on every infraction it's it's
the same thing it's like no no here's
what happens I would like the
Republicans to do at as little as
possible
as little as possible
little teeny teeny bit the least amount
they can do because right now they're
doing nothing yeah I I would ask they
only do a little bit it's kind of like
their friends and then maybe maybe after
that so uh one thing they can do I guess
is um how about in Colorado we get any
D.A any single one because there's no
statute of limitations on murder or San
Diego where Abdullahi also lived and San
Diego you got you got any Republicans
down there there's no statute of
limitations on murder indict Barack
Obama do it you spineless cowards I mean
can we just start with just let's just
start with the the Lefty weirdos that
are protesting all the time look at
Tennessee they've got a a republican
Governor they've got Republican DA's
right Bill Lee he's the the Republican
governor of Tennessee start hunting down
and Prosecuting every person that
trespassed in that Capital because
that's what they did you know charge
them with a felony charge them with
um you know
interrupting a civil proceeding right
that's four years in prison because all
our guys are sitting there rotting away
for that for four years just do the
least amount you can because right now
you're doing nothing
I I understand what you're the argument
you're making essentially it's a
narrative argument right um just which
is which is fair but uh I mean I I don't
care how we classify it I think that the
narrative art I think the narrative is
probably not going to be won by the
right
um because the narrative is going to be
at least be so heavily no The Narrative
is not going to be able to be dictated I
don't care about winning a narrative
against the left those people don't
matter to me it's like asking me what I
think about the people of France like
well I've heard about what they do I
don't care the issue is we keep going to
conservatives and asking telling them
putting it in their minds that what we
are asking for is lifting a two-ton
Stone when in fact we're asking
Republicans pick up a measly little
Pebble dude we are when we come out we
say we need our politicians to go out
and go after every infraction instead of
being like can we please get a single
Republican to do the least amount of
work possible yeah yeah I I get what
you're saying it's it's it's the results
that I'm after it's the the results of
that least amount of work that I want
because the results are what's going to
inhibit other political actors from
behaving that way in the future so yes I
get what you're saying about about
people in the minimum if people if
people think that
indicting Barack Obama is a tremendous
undertaking of abnormality that we must
now change our action and Go full force
and they won't expect it to happen if we
say the least yeah the least a
conservative D.A in Colorado or San
Diego could do is indict Obama for
murder that's the least they could do
then it's more like okay well that they
should be doing that tomorrow
uh yeah if you want to talk about
escalating you know 34 charges in 136
years in prison that's a whole other
story but right now I believe
Republicans and conservatives in this
country have become such such you know
it's funny because they I love how they
make fun of soy boys how their rights
are always making fun of soy boys yet
all the conservative has in terms of law
enforcement and DA's are the soiest of
soy boys listen to this an antifa soy
Boy made fun of by conservatives will
firebomb a building and then risk going
to prison for 30 years and a
conservative D.A will be like well I I
can't charge anybody with a crime I mean
I don't think the court worked that way
and who's the real soy boy they're
they're less than soy boys I mean
they're deranged people they're when
when the left Jesus say like there's a
big Mental Health crisis it's in this is
we have a huge Mental Health crisis and
it's nine times out of ten all these
deranged people on the left like to be
able to go and do that over some of the
issues that they are going and doing and
believing the narratives that they
believe they are absolutely deranged
I don't understand how they're deranged
I don't understand this Narrative of
these people being soy boys when there's
videos of them screaming at the top of
their lungs and smashing windows and I'm
just like yo they're they're like
psychotically aggressive some and then
but the like
I had that little one pull my hair
remember the antifa in Philly when I was
like filming so a soy boy pulled your
hair yeah like it was an answer nothing
about my hair the the the the the the
smallest thing a person could do in
terms of fighting back the most
rudimentary would be pulling hair we
can't even get a republican to indict a
a Democrat for the criminal actions they
have conducted it's because we it's
because we live in the logic of Herbert
my point is the people we accuse of
being soy boys are so much stronger than
your average Republican politician it's
it's laughable that people make fun of
them for being low-t soy boys I'm like
dude at least that guy went outside and
screamed the these conservative DA's are
doing nothing in fact many of them are
working with Democrats you want to talk
about Low T soy boys purposefully crawl
under the legs of a Democrat so they can
rest their feet and then you complain
the guy outside screaming and smashing
Windows is low T sorry I I I'm you're
absolutely right they are working
together too and that's why like PA is
the way that it is it's like purple and
all now our our GOP is so corrupt in NPA
that the Republican like uh nominees
that are winning like just little tiny
races or whatever are getting called by
the Democrat mayor congratulating them
they get they receive money you should
look into it like they receive money
from Democrat donors the Republicans in
Philadelphia itself like
it's it's baffling it's like really
mind-boggling but you're right they're
working together it's a lot it's not
just no the Republicans are like
Democrat political you know uh
submissives
yeah I mean it is you look at what they
do on TV I mean look at what we're
watching right now they indicted Donald
Trump a local district attorney a local
guy
in that's Donald Trump you made it tell
me Barack Obama blew up a kid blew him
up his cousin and a bunch of civilians
and Republicans are like wow you know I
don't know if I could do anything it's
part of Hawaii dude I was reading that
why they're not going after Trump for
any kind of war crimes because they
don't want to open that can of worms
that's everybody man that's the
administrations of of Obama carrying the
letter down the hall for Obama they
opened the can of worms by indicting
Trump yeah so how that would have been
at least more substantial than than this
at least you could what what qualifies
you for jurisdiction is I I wonder
abdulrahman al-alaki was born in Denver
he lived in San I believe San Diego so
um I could be wrong but let's just
figure out what area he was in and then
where is a conservative district
attorney to do what brag is doing to
announce criminal charges bring the
evidence before a grand jury uh oh it's
a conservative area of course they're
going to vote to indict and then
announce Barack Obama because there's no
statute of limitations on murder
especially of children is being formally
charged and will have to come and answer
for his crimes I'm ready
you know what man let's go go right
though let's go find them let's make
Cassandra go tackle them get them all on
the show and like force them for
something yeah let's start inviting
seriously that's supportive to you guys
well so we need to figure out what
jurisdiction they would have right so
the guy in New York it's because Trump
runs a business out of New York that's
what he's doing right you know so where
are the conservative district attorneys
or State's Attorneys or Adas or whatever
who will go before a grand jury with
evidence against any Democrat
is now the Democrats opened the can of
worms I'll start making one of myself
we'll come up now is the time for the
Republican party to I mean look the
Republican establishment is garbage so
they're not going to do anything
but now is the time the two-party
system's garbage I mean the two-party
system is is a is a a fault of the first
past the post voting system it's an
inevitability there's no other way it
could emerge and that's why you end up
with multi-factional parties so it's
just two the two-party system doesn't
really mean anything when you say two
parties it makes no sense it doesn't
mean anything a Libertarian will run as
a Republican and then and then win like
Thomas mass is a Libertarian Ron Paul is
a Libertarian Rand Paul's a Libertarian
it makes no sense to think that only a
Democrat or Republican can win because
if you start to think like that that's a
primary is true but that's what
primaries are for so so this idea that
people are like the two-partisan doesn't
work it's like dude you know they're
primaries right like the Democrats have
socialists they have corporatists they
have neolibs there's a whole bunch of
different people in the Democratic party
they all go up on stage they all state
their case and then one of them wins and
then it goes down to the leading
candidates Democrat Republican yeah but
even
ideas and you're running it and you're
you're a Libertarian that's running and
as as a conservative in like a GOP
Primary race that even if you have
better ideas and some good name ID the
the GOP party's gone to back the GOP
candidate they're they're not going to
back the libertarian right so there's an
issue with the private structure of the
two of the two parties for sure but let
me just stress right now I want to put
up that call to everybody who's
listening to uh make a call to your
local District Attorneys ask them why
they aren't well I'll put it this way
don't cold call
if you want to if you want to be active
figure out what crimes may have been
committed by a Democrat where your
conservative leaning district has
jurisdiction
and then call up the DM be like why
aren't you not indicting
I think I think it needs to be done I
think Barack Obama should be criminally
charged yes I think the D.A in uh just
whichever City
would have jurisdiction whatever County
would have jurisdiction uh or state
could be done Statewide
there could be State charges from
Colorado clearly violated his
constitutional rights to a to a trial
s
violated his rights I mean but I mean
it's not even about violating rights he
didn't kill abdur mananaki for doing
anything criminal no this is an outright
murder if a cop pulls out his gun walks
into a cage and shoots him in the head
there's there's no self-defense literal
murder
they may try and claim it but then you
look at them and say like no you you
knew the kid's father you hated the
kid's father
you were in a fight with the kid's
father and killed him and then you went
into an area by choice and killed the
kid and his cousin and other civilians
that's the other thing
you want to make the argument about the
about Abdullahi
oh you know it's the son of a terrorist
like okay what about the civilians in
the cafe Barack Obama doesn't have the
authority to murder civilians what about
the soldiers that shot the wrong person
or dropped the Drone bomb on the wrong
guy
or the commanders that ordered the Drone
bomb there's a difference between a
country we're actively at war with where
someone is following a legal order and
there's collateral damage which I think
is bad but not necessarily criminal and
Barack Obama ordering a drone strike on
a country we are not at war with
ordering a drone strike on a and yeah
that's the point ordering a drone strike
on a civilian restaurant killing
multiple civilians including an American
citizen so and I will absolutely state
for any person who is in a foreign
country right now waving the American
flag shooting anyone in which there has
been no declared formal War I think they
should be criminally charged as well all
the soldiers from Afghanistan Iraq the
last 20 years you think should be there
was an aumf for those Congress declared
authorization for use of military force
did Obama not have that Obama did not
have an authorization for use of
military force in Yemen to Target a
civilian Cafe and kill an American
yeah
the fact that he killed America an
American American citizens multiple
multiple American citizens like you you
have protections under the Constitution
that prevents the government from just
targeting you and killing you without a
trial like he didn't he he violated the
rights of two Americans one targeted and
while he targeted they said that it was
oh well he's a terrorist but there was
no trial to find him guilty of anything
they just shot a missile at him because
he was exercising his freedom of speech
and he was complaining about the US
government obviously saying making
terroristic threats or whatever but he
has that freedom he it the freedom of
speech you have the right to speak your
mind he was basically saying you know
Islamic fundamentalist things
um and his kid was definitely you you
make a citizen make an argument about
anwari they say that he was suspected of
being an Al-Qaeda that means he's Waging
War against the United States suspected
but but still if you are in a war zone
where was he it was in Pakistan or
something I don't know so you're in a
country first and foremost we're not at
war with then I do not believe that the
president has the right to just start
striking random countries now there
there I will I will do this for the sake
of the highest of high ground and steel
man argument you win on the Anwar
al-alaki issue he was an Al-Qaeda
terrorist okay you will never win on the
abdulrahman al-alalaki argument that
Yemen not at Warfare civilian Cafe no
reason to Target it American citizen who
had done nothing in the United States to
anyone no no justification for the
murder other than I believe the Obama
Administration wanted to send a message
to Al-Qaeda and to other organizations
we will kill your children
if you screw with us this is what you
get and I guarantee you there are many
people who saw that and said I can't do
this anymore they'll kill my children
yeah I think that was the point now the
argument they made was they were
targeting a terror leader and it was an
accident whoopsie yeah sure so okay uh
fine let's entertain that argument uh
Barack Obama if you're a police officer
and you see a guy running from the scene
of a crime and you think he is the
murder suspect when someone calls in and
says a guy just shot someone you see him
running you say freeze he turns around
and he's holding something in his hand
and starts to point at you and you go no
and you shoot him
I'm gonna be like okay that's like
manslaughter
that's like negligent homicide I don't
think you deserve jail time for that
that that's a tough question but if the
police make a mistake and kill an
innocent person there is accountability
in some fashion
if Barack Obama now let's put it this
way let's let's do a better one the cops
kicked the door into the wrong house
and then see they're in plain clothes
and they see a man standing in the
kitchen holding a knife and he yells get
out of my house so they shoot and kill
him okay that that's the wrong door like
okay yes so when Barack Obama drone
bombs a country we are not at war with
and kills a bunch of civilians
so the problem I see is anybody
convicting him of that however it would
be advantageous still embarrass him and
you know have him hire attorneys and
drown him in paperwork and all that
stuff because like why why why can't
anyone indict him for it oh they can
indict him absolutely I'm just saying
like you won't be convicted like uh in a
concert Republican District yeah would
um I think that I think that Republicans
don't like they they will follow the
beyond the shadow of a doubt reasoning
that's why they'll lose more exactly oh
that is why they'll lose and the left
doesn't do that like you know they it's
just different they they have a
conscience I feel like oh yeah Hillary
Clinton too she was Secretary of State
so Libya and all that stuff let's just
start layering on the indictments why
not the biggest mistake Trump made could
have been in jail literally for the
email Scandal but that is the thing that
is legit Owen Benjamin tweeted out today
uh you guys we're it's all with gang
Warfare man the world everything it's
all gang we're in a gang we have gang
leaders uh and to pretend like it's not
that way that they're not just ready to
break bones is like just Know Your Role
know your place in the system or you're
going to be taken out of the system and
this is a pretty Observer observant he's
true it's horrible but that's actually
an inverted way to think about it gangs
are micro governments that form when
there's a power vacuum gangs are gangs
are literally just I don't even use the
word gang he was saying that it's like
car like all government all this stuff
it's all just rule of force uh they have
they're not going to indict each other
they're going to make sure that their
Rule and law stays in place like I don't
want to just be like okay Nazis do
whatever you want you're like I don't
want to be that guy that just bows down
to the authority but it was observant
like if you're gonna change it it's not
through using their tactics
it's got to be some unforeseen
technology or something
yeah
Cosmic surgeon said Tim's D.A as
jurisdiction on something lead Tim yes
absolutely I will be uh I will be
talking with uh local government and uh
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com go to
timcast.com click join us and if you're
a new member and you want to get access
to the VIP chat where you can ask
questions call into the show it's the 25
a month option however there's also the
10 a month option after six months you
instantly get upgraded into the VIP chat
room other than that you'll get access
to the this the the the uh VIP or I'm
sorry you'll get the IRA
IRL live Lounge there we go I got it and
uh that chat appears on the screen
during our uncensored portion portion of
the show I can't talk anymore all right
we're gonna read your super chats let's
go Bertman uh super chats the burdening
will continue until morale
ah Bert has taken over he owns the
Discord now Raymond g Stanley Jr says in
that case the burdening will never end
I'm all for that I don't mind for those
that aren't aware you have to be a
member and hang out in the Discord
server with all of these people who have
decided that for some reason one of our
writers Chris Bertman is there is their
leader now he's made a cult I guess yeah
I was talking to him down in the green
room today about that exactly yeah yeah
he was uh he was laughing maniacally yes
he was actually it was it was strange I
was concerned
all right free men Die free says they'll
drag the trial out until after the
election then drop the charges that
means the same thing as uh I don't I
don't know about that I think that they
will drag Discovery and all that out and
then when he's supposed to be actively
out campaigning they will have him
sitting in a courtroom and and then he
won't be able to participate as normal
for sure yep yep I have to wonder why
Trump surrendered I I don't know why
come and take me and have and have 800
Maga people surrounding his house and
Santa's right like hey I will and and
the members of Congress they should have
been out there with the people stand in
front of Mar-A-Lago with their arms
crossed you're gonna have to come
through all that they would have dropped
it immediately they should have if
Donald Trump said these are clearly
political charges
the claims made have already passed the
statute of limitations and I will you
will not drag money time or energy out
of me for false and frivolous charges
you're welcome to come to Florida if you
believe otherwise it would have created
a huge press storm and then once the
indictment was released even CNN called
it underwhelming and said we've already
known about this it's been two years
then people would have been like there's
no real charges here Alvin Bragg would
have been extremely embarrassed members
of Congress would be saying like what is
this it would humiliate the Democrats
Trump would still raise money off of it
and Trump would look stronger
think about how motivated the baseball
he says no come and take me and then
everybody lines up I mean like like John
6 style but peaceful just I don't think
they would lock in the house I think
they would but they wouldn't need to I
think he would just be like it's not
going to happen it would be cool though
that would be a moment if they were if
like you had the the Maga base
surrounding Mar-A-Lago like yeah you
ain't taking them and with already after
desanta said I'm not gonna get involved
in extradition it would have been
Monumental ready to rumble says make the
chat members only today too many trolls
what we have now for you uh my friend is
instead of being a member on YouTube
become a member of timcast.com and join
the Discord server and then you are in a
screened chat room with other people
all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says if you're not
already now is the time to be angry to
be angry into action be more vocal with
your Normie friends talk about the
extremeness of the democratic party now
isn't the time to sit on the sidelines
of a fence I'd put it this way when I'll
sit next to that dude who who wanted the
Jan Sixers to be executed you know he's
he was really angry and there's no way I
can say to him look man you're wrong you
can't call for that he'd get angrier the
only thing you can say is yeah I don't
know man like all I know is it's like
indicting a former president like you
start arresting the president they're
gonna arrest back and then this country
is going to fall apart like they need to
chill out and then it's like okay well
that's reasonable we all should chill
out yeah like I don't know everyone's
kind of lost their mind don't you think
everybody should kind of chill out
that's you got to start somewhere you
can't start by walking up to somebody
who disagrees with you and just being
like you're wrong
I look at them and I I'm like I hate you
and you disgust me and I want you to be
nowhere near me well then you're not
gonna I know that I know that I'm not
but I wasn't winning them over in the
first place anyway but I I am I'm
furious I I was around 2016-17 I was
winning people over writing like
diatribes on Facebook but now I just I
have been so angry at everything that
they're doing that I can't it's almost
like I can't control it anymore it's
visceral I see like a blue haired demon
and I'm ready to explode this is what
they want they're destroying the United
States I know civilization yeah absolute
demoralization
both in the form of morals and morale
but I'm a woman so like that's expected
I'm emotional do you dip off the
internet ever what just for like two
days oh yeah yeah yeah I took a break
actually just like for the last two days
up until yesterday actually I wasn't
even on there all day today either I was
like frantically doing a space on the
way down so I can get more information
about what's going on today but yeah
yeah it's a buff so what is what is this
um
Jay says did you see what happened to
the Disney stockholder meeting Iger may
have screwed up severely no I didn't
what happened
I didn't see they're gonna indict Iger
I'm just kidding I don't know Jay you
should uh include your Super Chat the
context because otherwise I just I don't
know I don't know what this refers to
I'm assuming something bad happened and
he got yelled at for some reason I don't
know I can look it up
all right Aaron bonestell says you
should have a look at your Apple podcast
uploads last few that I've listened to
randomly skips ahead then skips back not
playing the parts that was skipped most
of the last was Kirk talking that's
informative hmm
randomly skips ahead then skips back
I have no I don't know might that be an
issue with like the apples don't for the
for that we just upload the raw file
don't we sorry
it's just it's it I I don't know what to
tell you on that one um sorry I mean
honestly that could be you that sounds
it sounds like it could be there's a lot
of there's a lot of variables in this
but yeah sorry about that Max Reddick
says Tim have you been watching any of
David Pacman's stuff lately the dude is
losing us check it out uh David Pacman
completely lost his mind yeah uh so I
pulled up his YouTube and it's like
yo like it's just it's just Trump Trump
trump Trump trump Trump trump Trump
trump Trump trump
look at this like leftist talking yet
he's well here okay let's count he's
like a YouTuber from 2007 Trump yeah
okay so two two for Trump
Trump trump
marger Taylor green April fools so we're
what five of eight videos nine of uh
sorry uh six of Nine videos about Trump
uh Trump again so Trump trump Trump
trump
guns he's an addiction
Trump Trump trump bro it's like what are
you doing
Trump Trump trump Trump trump Trump
trump Trump trump Trump trump he wants
everyone to know that he doesn't like
Donald Trump that's crazy the orange man
is very bad but I've got you know on my
channel I've got like a dating video
like like here's some women talking
about dating like here's a woman talking
about this here's what I'm talking about
that here's uh I got one about
immortality Ray Kurzweil talks about
becoming Immortal in the next few years
you know I got one about shop uh armed
shop shopkeeper fights with Thief I want
to do one on surrogacy if you ever want
to do one on surrogacy give me a call
because I'm very passionate but I just
mean like in terms of things I'm
interested in talking about it's not
just like Joe Biden Joe Biden Joe Biden
Joe Biden Joe Biden Joe Biden you know
granted like putting out six videos per
day there was a lot of democrat talk for
sure but on his channel it's just like
you go through and it's like just Trump
specifically Donald Trump not the
Republicans not congress not laws
the clicks he's not even on social media
anymore
it's like I think that's the the toilet
flush of algorithmic algorithmic death
yes yeah when a person is like this is
the only thing my audience responds to
now so I'll do more of it and then you
isolate and alienate more and more of
your audience until you get to the point
where the only thing you can talk about
it's an addiction yeah it's like a CNN
death spiral yep yeah well you know what
he did it to himself and he's even
getting ragged on by the left so you
reap what you're so man that's that's
death now yep
Catherine Molina says are going to talk
about brick now bricks uh well it's been
bricks for a while yeah there's always
bricks it's going to be uh Brix is uh or
something Saudi Arabia oh yeah or Brooks
because South Africa and Saudi Arabia
and who else is joining turkey uh I
think it wasn't it turkey was it I think
turkey and Saudi Arabia yeah yeah turkey
so it was Turkey so brixtus turkey's a
nuclear power yeah they're the keys to
the Black Sea that makes a lot of sense
yeah are you sure about the other part
of NATO yeah no they're not I don't know
that they're part of NATO either she's
trying to Brazil India T-Rex Pet Shop
says Ian does Mr boca's Food have corn
wheat soy or animal byproducts in it
Purina is notorious for bad ingredients
vet gets kickbacks from companies
promoting bad food sometimes if it has
any of those ingredients you should
switch you know it has like animal liver
he's not he's on medicated food yeah
it's like very specific low phosphate or
I just switched to this outrageously
priced from like a trial for that Frozen
dry food like it's like real meat but
it's Dr like freeze-dried real quick and
you stick it in I'm waiting for it to
come will you microwave it for a short
second or something no you're kind of
like let it all you know it's like has
bone broth treats and stuff in there for
them but it's all raw food and then it's
like freeze-dried for to like maintain
the nutritional value and then I don't
know cat food dog food oh I have a dog
what is this Austin Scott says gold is
the third worst performing precious
metal at 20 since the year 2000 lithium
is over 450 the Palladium is where it's
at yeah yeah uh I think I think
palladium's actually gone down oh
lithium's gone way down it's going to be
used in Cold Fusion that's cool but like
if you're talking about exchange people
aren't going to be like oh I'll take
lithium's down 34 what is it 34 this
month
gold is up nine percent Silver's up 18.
platinum's up four
well
yeah I don't know man
you find a good financial advisor to
tell you what to do about all that stuff
Raymond g Stanley Jr says freedomic
stand is where it's at I'll be there one
day
it's under construction really annoying
how long it takes
I'm I'm super I can't even describe how
annoyed and angry I am with it now being
almost two years how lucky we are to be
annoyed
yeah yeah but like I I've seen in the
two years that we've been trying to get
this built cities be built like I'm
exaggerating but I've seen like actual
projects come to completion where
construction companies come in and snap
their fingers and I and they they time
I'm like dude it's been two years
um that's why you need the Amish they'll
come in and build you a whole Barn of
the day there's a variety of issues one
is
uh Comcast won't install the the
internet line you've had problems with
that before right yeah that's that's
just normal rural stuff yeah and even so
at first they were like the materials
don't exist blame the shutdowns the
economic collapse and all that stuff but
you know whatever
anyway yeah yeah almost two years now
waiting for this thing to uh this this
this place to be done we'll get there
soon Chad yeah I'm well I'm ready to
make something happen so we'll see the
good news though is uh the club for
elite members and uh and and other
in-person members is probably going to
go up real soon yeah so we got a
building in West Virginia it's got three
floors first floors uh coffee shop floor
plans been drawn up they're going to be
installing the plumbing and we're that's
moving along castbrew.com already exists
we have our coffee packaging branding
and all that stuff you can now pre-order
cast Brew Coffee second floor is going
to be a hangout with Games movies and
things like that third floor is the
ultra private social club for elite
members and we're hoping to get a gaming
license for poker so we can have a small
Poker Club where we will film poker with
the boys I love that I love there's so
many people that would want to do poker
with the boys like that I that I know oh
and I love our little well tons of
members of Congress especially like
everybody like poker is just poker with
the boys exactly what it is we're not
Pros you know maybe some pros will come
by sometime this is not going to be a
pro poker show it's going to be a table
smack talk show where you have people
hanging out having a good time and just
playing a game for fun nice and then
it's going to be funny when you're like
I can't believe Matt Gates got bluffed
out of that that hand he was he was was
sitting on you know not straight and
then he just he thought the guy had the
flush and it's like Alex Jones has got
like seven two off suit and wins it's
gonna be so much fun see I don't I don't
Gamble and I don't know how to play or
anything like that but okay but you know
what I'm saying like I've never I don't
gamble so I don't know how to play like
any type of Poker what I'll do though is
I'll bring the cigars and I'll call
around and light them off we're gonna
bring your drinks that'll be that'll be
my contribution that's that's the big
debate but uh
it should be boys only poker well the
gag is we're gonna have the women wear
fake mustaches that's really funny and
then we're gonna be like you know no
girls here and then but it should be I
think that there's that's another thing
that's missing from society is like men
having like male Fellowship time where
the boys hang out with the boys without
the girls and like do manly things
together I think it's a necessary
component now every all like the women
are like oh you're going golfing and
you're leaving me but like men need that
men need that camaraderie they used to
have what hunting lodges like men need
that but hold on just I want you to
imagine
you get you know like maybe Charlie Kirk
and say Ian maybe and Phil maybe uh Matt
Gates and they're playing poker against
uh with Carrie Lake who's got a double
shot of whiskey and a cigar and she's
staring down Matt and then she shoves
all in and then Matt's just like I'm out
and he folds and then she flips over
seven two and it's like damn it'd be
good content for sure that would be
hilarious that would be good content
yeah for sure I'm really excited for it
and uh the more I'm learning when I'm
mentioning this to like our guests a lot
of members of Congress a lot of people
have in the show they all play they're
like I would love to be there that's
gonna be so amazing like Troy Nails was
here and he's super excited because he
loves poker I like it uh Charlie Kirk
said he plays a little bit uh Matt Gates
definitely plays I don't know if you
know maybe maybe he'll come down for it
but I know that uh he plays he would
definitely come down yeah I think it'd
be hilarious Alex Jones Michael malice
Destiny plays Destiny the the liberal oh
I know I actually made Destiny kind of
although we hate each other we get along
it's not like me and Hunter Avalon who I
hate he said uh Destiny said he used to
used to play tournaments and things like
that and I was like bro you gotta come
down to me hilarious you with Alex Jones
like playing this game is going to be
just the funniest and it's not political
like the idea is We're not gonna sit
here and yell at each other over
politics it'll come up a little bit but
the idea is to actually just hang out
and have fun and it'd be interesting to
see people's behavior in that type of
situation like I would love to see how
certain people act because you know
they're when you're playing poker it's
different than when you're out there
giving a speech or you know trying to
get your point across well I got to say
this it's not gambling I know it's not
gambling it's not like but you just said
twice when I say gamble I mean like
poker Blackjack like those I consider
them gambling games so I'll be I'm I
will be right for you first so like for
card games if you go to a casino you sit
at a table and play blackjack you're
gambling
right right if you Lisa sat down with
Phil Hellmuth you're not gambling he's
taking all your money in snap of his
fingers pretty much true yeah because
like it's it's not gambling I actually
know a famous po like a professional
poker player he used to be Harry kalas's
in Philly like his son and he's an opera
singer and a professional poker player
isn't that bizarre gambling implies that
there is is a game a chance and there is
no chance that you're gonna win much
skill in this case yeah yeah
so it's funny because uh I've had the
argument back at me that luck is
involved in it and even a lot of Pros
think so and I'm like sure just like if
you train for American Ninja Warrior and
you suck at the you know the salmon
ladder or something and you're hoping
this time around the final stage doesn't
include it congratulations it's a game
of luck because they didn't include the
one obstacle you're bad at it now come
on get out of here if you if if you
train for something you have strengths
and weaknesses and so I think that
applies to a game like poker as well
clearly anybody who who's actually
played the game knows it if you don't
know what you're doing and don't know
how to play you just lose really really
quickly like any other game that's why
he's winning for a while I'll have to
bring him down you would love my brother
I'll bring I'll bring my brother down
and hunt and play but you know yes you
can get lucky you can play your best and
still lose so that element exists but
like I said you could be you know really
good at golf and then what oh no there's
a sand trap I'm really bad at you know
so it's like or the wind the wind can
pick up yeah it's not a game of luck
because it's windy one day and you're
like man this sucks how am I supposed
it's too windy you know no it's skill
you you have to adjust for those things
yeah but anyway Let's uh let's read some
more Super chats
Eric Christensen says a feminist will
spend all day telling you she doesn't
need a man until there's a spider
scratch bogus's belly or whatever
wherever he likes it for us I did that
earlier yeah bogus actually doesn't mind
if you uh rub his belly like a lot of
cats will just you know they'll slash
you because it's like you're touching
them in their weak point and cats don't
like it but bogus will actually stretch
out and like you know and then you can
rub his belly and he just rolls with it
yeah bogus is a chill dude he seems to
be getting better huh oh yeah
good cats are kind of growing on me I
was always a dog person thought cat
people were weird put their ground on me
and my brother had a wife and she has a
cat now so now I'm being nicer to cats
so Anthony Graham says I think Lisa is
spot on no one likes to say this out
loud but women generally are more
emotional funny how media can twist your
emotions to vote that's all they do they
play on women's emotions and and that's
why we keep hearing the the Suburban mom
narrative Suburban mom Suburban moms and
that's who everything is targeted to if
you think about the ads that you watch
on TV almost all of them are targeted to
towards women because women are the ones
that may basically spend the money for
the household right and so you have
almost all of Television geared towards
women and we're telling women that
you're happier single and you're happier
you know and having abortions and you're
happier having a career and your
husband's an idiot like think about
every commercial that you know the men
in the commercial are always idiots and
the women are like oh I'm the real smart
one right yeah like it is totally
poisoned and perverted
everybody's mind I tell my daughter now
like your main job is to get married and
have babies like I literally tell her
that as you know I'm making herself
exactly like uh what most guys think uh
they want a woman to sound like well you
should you should uh tell her that when
she's old old enough I don't know how
short she is but you shouldn't this but
I'm saying people you should I'm kidding
by the way but have her just test the
testosterone levels of the man and make
sure it's above a certain level because
what I was going to say is the voting
thing isn't about women it's about the
level of testosterone yeah and that
correlates with aggression and
agreeableness low-team males are also
very agreeable
if you've if so you know women and Low T
men will follow the crowd because it's
safe
there's agreeable test I took those
tests and they said I was agreeable like
lower than the thing and I was like guys
I'm not agreeable was that a Jordan
Peterson's yeah how agreeable what
percent I think it was like 48 or
something like that like like it was
like low it's like 48 it was under the
50 thing and uh the only thing that I
got that was like unusual was the
conscientiousness which is weird because
like I mean yeah I'm sloppy sometimes
but I like get all my work done I'm
reliable and stuff so I don't know I
don't know
um last minute I'm here Louis T says Tim
Poole casting on YouTube watching Rumble
that's right and timcast.com is hosted
on Rumble servers and the uncensored
after show uses Rumble infrastructure
nice and uh we then show rumble on
YouTube and tell people to support
channels on Rumble how about how how's
uh how's that for
doing a show on YouTube platform
pollination Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Discord great first step I'm on that
white pill so we have with the Discord
server the elite club which is 100 bucks
a month very few people are in it the
idea is for for now it's just the
Discord it's a way for people to network
who want to meet like-minded people and
then work on projects together in New
York this is the thing I've seen a lot
of people in chapter like a hundred
bucks a month are you crazy and it's
like in New York there are people who
spend fifty thousand dollars a year to
be a member of a social club so they can
get access to Executives and VPS of
major media companies and tech companies
you show up to these clubs you pay your
dues there's free food and drinks next
thing you know you're sitting next to
the guy who runs one of the biggest
media companies in the world so they
gladly pay this yeah we have to have
social clubs like that for the time
being
what we're doing is this Saturday when
we go to Austin I am going to tell all
of the elite members exactly where I am
to come hang out and it's going to be a
whole lot of fun it's going to be a
pseudo Meetup we're going to be in
Austin this Saturday and then after I
arrive at the location we're planning on
being I'm going to post a message to our
Elite members like this is where I'm at
I'm at come hang out and I'm not going
to say where it's going to be right now
but it's a public space for security
reasons I'm gonna wait till I'm there
but that's kind of the point and then
once we have the new venue open with the
third floor private club where in talks
with government to prop to get proper
licensing for a table license so we can
have poker with the boys actual buy-in
games and then our Elite members will be
able to go in and play games we're
trying to figure out right now depending
on the legality whether or not we do a
rake or simple uh membership
and and uh I'm not interested in making
money off the games I'm interested in
having a club that makes money to stay
in the club so if people if if we get a
a few poker tables the one thing you'll
see at big poker clubs is either a seat
rental fee or a rake which means the
dealer takes money out of each pot and
puts it in a bin for the company
I would probably bypass both of those
things and just be like so long as the
members are paying dues and then the
table games are no rake no no rental fee
you guys play the games among yourselves
only thing we got to do is tip the
dealer so we're trying to figure that
out though because it might not be
possible but the idea is to make it less
of a we want to monetize you having fun
with your friends and more of a
everybody pitches in to support the
structure where you can come hang out
and do whatever you want within certain
reason obviously no acting a fool and
stuff like that
all right Jacob says this show only
works because Serge's expert button
pushing huh that is true thank you very
there there are programs have been
around for a while that automatically
switch and they're just not good for
shows like this it works for like one or
two people doing a stream maybe yeah I
thought I was pretty good at pushing
people's buttons I think you still are
sure sure
all right Ed Reeves says homeschooling
has been illegal in Germany since 1919.
don't put it past the Department of
Education in lockstep with the teachers
union to push to make that happen here
christianclassicalschools.org it's a
homeschool kind of method very small
classes at least check it out I swear by
it it's absolutely the best decision I
ever made for my my life my kids
anything
christianclassical.org David red with a
big Super Chat and YouTube tells me to
celebrate the first Super Chat from
David Redd well thank you very much
thank you I appreciate it I love that
name it means beloved David my brother's
name
all right he then says send a Super Chat
without a message support right-wing
attorneys and help us primary rhinos we
are less than 10 percent of the legal
profession seek us out and promote us if
this is not apparent to you get out of
your bubble
well we got to get more uh conservative
DA's man
Soros is funding all these DA's to win
that's part of the problem I should open
up like a D.A pack
yes I mean like I only had to run them
so I don't know that's a really good you
know what's funny is I talk I talk to
all these conservatives and libertarian
types who are like we know people with
lots of money or we are we ourselves are
very wealthy and I'm like okay can
somebody organize something to do
something because like y'all have the
money you're just sitting on it I know
how to do it that's what I need to do
okay Lisa is going to start a D.A I'll
start a D.A Super PAC yeah and then we
will use our Network and and find
like-minded individuals who have money
to donate and then you can have a
reverse Soros where good DA's get in to
actually prosecute crime and help make
people yeah I should really actually we
should really actually look into doing
that I will I will absolutely look into
that and see what how I can get it
started ASAP I'm sure good idea I'm sure
like half the people who have been
guests on the show be willing to
contribute it's not like I mean how many
how many times have I made like campaign
videos for other people too like I could
whip up a video a sora's video for that
too and get it all over Twitter
Catherine Molina says talk to Lauren
bobert about a conservative Colorado D.A
that's a really good point and of all
the people who I think would be
interested in pursuing something like
that Lauren Butler it's probably one of
them
yeah all right it was Denver though so
my new mission it was uh Abdul rahman's
from was born in Denver
so I don't know who would have
jurisdiction because he was in Yemen
they might say oh no no no you know they
might say it doesn't because he was
killed in Yemen's Yemen
all right what do we got Melissa wood
says late to the party because I was
putting my kids to bed but if you think
we wouldn't bring Banana Republic
tactics back home is laughable I love
the USA but our tactics are coming home
by the NSA
yup
the thing that the U.S has traditionally
done overseas are starting to happen
here that's why some people think it's
on purpose yeah it seems like it
Ray Jacobs says Roman history is
repeating itself it's like the fall of
the Roman Republic and the crisis of the
third Century all rolled into one oh I
saw I saw me about this actually with uh
it's like the fall of the Republic with
Wi-Fi and Twitter it's always at the
hands of sexual Revolution just saying
yeah um
but also a credit crunch happened yep
exactly yeah yeah it's very interesting
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends if you do
like it because that's the the bat
that's that's the one way that podcasts
actually get bigger is when people say I
like it and they tell their friends but
also go to timcast.com click join us
become a member and hang out in the
Discord we're going to have an
uncensored members only show on the
front page of timcast.com in about 10
minutes you don't want to miss it you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally at timcast Lisa
do you want to shout anything out I
don't know if you want to follow me you
can find me and all my other stuff at
Lisa Elizabeth on Twitter and it links
to everything else you got a show people
can fall um I'm doing one live streams
with James klug on his channel on
Tuesdays and Thursdays we're clear we're
clearly not doing it tonight I was
helping him with that and then I also do
like this thing for this other company
but it's real Rel America news on
Facebook and YouTube the show you're
doing James is that on James the channel
yeah yeah that's James what time does
that go up until 10 o'clock so after
after this you can well our members only
is 10 10. 10 Easter yeah well it can be
after that we go like so we've been just
doing them for fun but um we go for two
hours I guess so and you know so 10
Eastern seven Pacific and we just go and
just have some fun it's we had we had
Vince Dale last week and Anthony cabassa
and you know cool the good ones right on
I am philibonti Phil that remains on
Twitter Philip remains official on
Instagram Philip remains on YouTube
give me a follow I'm Ian Crossland hi
everyone hello and goodbye have a nice
evening see you later
and I am search.com everyone keeps
telling me on Discord I'm still thinking
about it for now just argue with me on
Twitter at server.com and we're next
week we're going to be so this Saturday
I'm flying to Austin and then the whole
week we're doing shows Tim castero live
from Austin then Friday is our timcast
IRL live on stage special event and uh
yeah at the ball game it's gonna be a
whole lot of fun it sold out a long time
ago so I'm really excited for this and
then the next day is the minds event at
the Vulcan so that should be a whole lot
of fun as well but uh for now we are
going to get that live show set up at
timcast.com so head over to the front
page should be up in about 10 minutes
and we will see you all there